- [Kelly] We've all had shows,
that didn't go the way we planned.
So have you ever had a show that you
were like oh no?
Like something bad happened?
- So the Menzel girls,
we have weak bladders
even before childbirth.
So um.
- [Kelly] Like when you pee?
- [Idina] Just like jogging.
- [Kelly] laugh?
- Like you laugh yeah.
- [Kelly] Okay.
(Both laughing)
- And then when you sing.
And then if you're singing a lot you know
you're drinking a lot of water.
So if something happens to me on stage
really funny that takes me by surprise.
I just have no there's no way.
And I've peed.
And then my wonderful
friend Joby Horrigan,
who's my dresser from all Broadway shows
she's been with me.
In Wicked once I had black tights.
Opaque black tights on
underneath the big gown.
I peed in them and the tights just
sapped it all up.
And then I got off stage
and I was like Jobes!
And I handed my friend
who I love so much who
does not deserve to take
urine-filled tights to the.
- [Kelly] Dude.
Candace is right back here my stylist.
Like she is laughing right now,
the things that have
happened in quick changes.
- [Idina] It's so gross.
But she is my best friend.
And I would do anything for her
especially cause she handled my
urine-stained tights.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But then I went back out commando
and then went sang
Defying Gravity you know?
(Both laughing)
(Audience cheering)
- I was like.
(singing final belt of Defying Gravity)
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
Oh my God.
That's amazing that that was the song.